celui-ci gars on se trouve aujourd'hui à
clamart dans le 92 et bien poursuivre
bien ses premières heures de confinement
puisqu'il est actuellement 14h30 et donc
je vais vous montrer un peu comment
est-ce que ça se passe en tout cas ici
dans le 92
dans cette petite ville qui quitte la
main
[Musique]
alors ça fait dix ans que je suis parti
j'ai croisé une seule voiture de police
aucun barrage pour le moment pourtant
j'ai changé de quartier
je trouve actuellement dans une zone un
peu plus pavillonnaires ou quand vous
pouvez le voir derrière moi il n'y a
absolument personne
contrairement au centre qui tout à
l'heure où il y avait la pharmacie et
les centres les centres commerciaux
donc on va continuer on va progresser
jusqu'à rencontrer un barrage et puis je
vous tiens au courant
[Musique]
alors on se trouve maintenant sur un axe
très emprunté c'est une route qui relie
clamart meudon fontenay-aux-roses et
châtillon une route vraiment beaucoup
emprunté est en temps normal là hormis
en mixez-les que quelques voitures et
quelques revues quelques passants ça
reste relativement calme et désert pour
le moment comme vous allez voir
il ya encore du passage mais c'est quand
même
c'est quand même très bien
[Musique]
on retrouve maintenant sur l'avenue de
verdun qui nourrit châtillon je suis
arrivé ici sans rencontrer le moindre
contrôle de police un accès extrêmement
prix que celui qui qui relie montrouge 7
sion avec la mare à paris et j'allais
vous dire que j'avais connu qu'un seul
contrôle et là j'en vois en face de moi
nous qu'on va aller se rapprocher de
voir la voiture de police qui redémarre
qui a certainement dû contrôler c'est ce
scooter
ce n'est pas en barrages c'est bel et
bien
non
[Applaudissements]
voilà des voitures mobile comme comme
ç'avait été annoncée par christophe
castaner hier soir
[Musique]
donc après 30 minutes donc de balade et
bien j'ai vu 0 point de contrôle deux
voitures de police ces mondiaux voitures
de police et beaucoup de gens qui font
du sport beaucoup de gens donc en
jogging et c'est beaucoup de gens qui
vont faire leurs courses
donc pour l'instant très peu de
policiers mais les consignes sont
clairement respectée alors après avoir
si tout le monde a son laissez-passer le
tableau papier mise à disposition par le
gouvernement
mais pour l'instant on va très peu de
contrôles de ce genre de papier donc en
tout cas dans le 92 ou en tout cas dans
à clamart et à châtillon il n'y a pas
trop de pas trop de compromis voilà